what's up ron how we doing brother doing
great john
uh really really appreciative for what
you do for us
well i'm appreciative of you for giving
me a shout man how can i help this
morning
yeah so um been married for five years
the love of my life um best five years
ever
raising two kids together one
kink in our marriage that yeah that i
want to get rid of
my wife has some pretty fragile mental
health
and she gets triggered often and i think
in a very logical solution-based way
and does it really work for her when she
is in those triggered states
and actually heightens her her emotions
um when i'm trying to provide her
solutions yeah oh
ron are you are you a solution giver
i am great so i i'm
trying to get some advice on you know
what i can do to step outside of that
solution-based mindset and just
empathize with her
when she's going through some of the
things that i may not think of
as big of a deal as she thinks they are
um
but you know i just want to you know
kind of slow myself down
and step outside of that uh giving her
solutions and just
really be in the moment and empathize
with her so when you tell her
she's number one thanks for being a guy
who's willing to look in the mirror and
say
maybe i'm contributing to this and so
high five brother i appreciate you
um so uh when you say she's got a lot of
mental health or a fragile mental health
what does that mean
real quick what does that mean um she
she grew up with an
alcoholic parent okay so
yeah so um her whole life
was a was a gap right was it was her
parent abusive or just
absent or just an addict
a little a little bit abusive um she's
she spent a lot of our childhood seeking
validation um
right you know from yeah so
it really triggers her when she's
seeking validation and then doesn't get
it now in her adult stage
yeah um especially from her parents
right right so that's a whole other
phone call right how to deal with those
folks
um so paint me a picture of a scenario
right she is struggling she is spinning
out
um she has somebody at work says
something to her
that you would normally just laugh off
and she comes home
and she is curled up on the couch in a
ball and you're like whoa what happened
and she tells you and your first thought
is that's not even a big deal
what do you do right what do you do next
just uh my uh this is kind of
embarrassing to say out loud hey listen
we are in it together man i promise you
whatever you're about to say i've
probably done too
yeah i i really just tell her like you
know don't don't let it affect you that
much like you're stronger than
what you're displaying right now um you
know those people don't have an
influence on your life just
really don't let that don't let it get
to you that that much
right kind of the route i take and so
the word you
you so listen number one i know that you
care about her
and that's why you're trying to help her
in that way and so the fact that you're
not a dismissive
partner right you're not just like
whatever dude and you don't just leave
good for you okay i know that you're
reaching out and you're trying to love
her the best you know how
and you got two knucklehead little kids
running around there too right when all
this is going on
right right so you said it perfectly so
i'm just gonna help you connect the dots
that are already in your own heart and
mind
earlier you said as a child which is
common of
of kids of whose parents are addicts
she was chasing validation and she
wanted to be
valid to them she wanted them to connect
with her she wanted them to notice her
and value her
and addicts don't they value their
addictions they value their unplugging
right their disconnection and so when
she says hey this happened
what she really wants is for her husband
to validate her your feelings are real
and when you try to solve those feelings
with info with information
her are you in my valid alarms start
ringing off the hook
because you are saying those aren't
valid what you should be doing is fill
in the blank
and so think of it in terms of
validation now here's the deal we all
have feelings and our feelings
are important and they lie to us right
they're not always
truthful the way we work through whether
they're truthful or not
is being safe are we in circumstances
where we are safe or we're okay
and so the greatest gift you could give
to your wife
is the idea of validation
your presence and so the next time she's
struggling in fact i would pre-struggle
before she starts struggling i would
start setting it up and you can tell her
hey i talked to delony and
here's a thing he wants us to try and
it's literally brother like 30 days
a month or two months of every single
day i want you to sit down before she
leaves for work before you go to work
and i want you to hold her hands and
look her in the eye just for a weird
awkward 10 seconds
and say i love you how's today going so
far and it may be
six o'clock in the morning and she could
say dude i just got up it's going
fine and you can say thank you for
sharing that
because what you're doing is you're
practicing
being present but not giving advice and
it's something you're going to have to
practice i know you want to fix her
mental health which you can't do
but you can change the way you respond
to things
and i want you to not think of your wife
as a car that you can fix
or i don't want you to think of a
problem at work that you have to solve i
want you just to think of
somebody that you love and then when you
get home from work and you see that
she's had a rough day or a great day
i want you to do that again i want you
to grab her hands and look her in the
eye for an awkward 10 seconds
and then i want you to say how was today
and if she says
this happened and it sucks and it was
awful and it was the worst thing ever
and i can't breathe and i just want to
have four glasses of wine
i want you to tell her um well forget
the wine part
not four glasses of wine i can help but
i want you to tell her
um thank you so much for sharing that
with me
i appreciate you being vulnerable and i
love you and then i want you to hug her
for about 30 seconds or 60 seconds
without stopping
and then let that be that and you're
gonna feel like there's so much left
unsaid and i didn't help her i didn't
fix her
my guess is she's pretty smart is she
pretty smart
a genius yeah there you go so think of
this
she doesn't need your information dude
she knows she's smart
what she needs is you to validate her
and not through words
she needs you to validate her through
connection and touch and through
presence and the beautiful thing here is
man i'm literally smiling if you watch
this on youtube i'm smiling
because i know you're a good guy and i
know you're gonna you want to
not just give her the right answers i
know you want to love your wife the best
you can
yeah and that's yeah man that is every
every guy who works in my space wants to
just meet guys who want to
love their partners with all their
hearts and your
beautiful wife has that and so the
practice for you
is not trying to solve her problems
here's another tip
if she continues to ask to talk about
the same thing the same thing the same
thing
ask her are you inviting me into this
conversation do you want my advice
or do you want me to be present
you sound like you're are you are you
hearing this or is it is it making sense
or not making sense
it's it's all it's all click it's it's
all
stuff that i've had pieces uh pieces too
but
just couldn't put the whole puzzle
together um you know
my wife and i have had multiple
conversations about this this is why i'm
finally reaching out
um i'm just like i was just kind of lost
but
you know the definitely the looking into
her eyes and
asking her you know hey how was your day
we don't do that ever you know we often
we often do not do that it's more so
coming
to me when something actually arises um
that has triggered her so
she was she worked a separate schedule
than i do you know i
am hvac technicians i work during the
day she's a waitress so she works during
the night
um so we often don't have that connect
time yeah
um to be able to do that so you know
making time for that
is a big deal um you know that was
that was a huge piece of the puzzle that
was missing for me and
on the way home from your hvac job if
you have to pull over on the side of the
road
and grab some wildflowers
if you have to run into a store and grab
her favorite something or other if on
the back
of some old air conditioning ducts
tape that you got off of an old house i
want you to write her a note
every day that jess says
who you are is beautiful and i love you
and i want you to constantly constantly
show up for her not with information but
with you
because you're awesome and what's going
to happen over time is she's going to
begin to
her shoulders will drop she won't search
for validation from you because she will
feel it
at her in her soul all right in her
mitochondria she will feel you
and then she will feel safe and you know
who else is going to start feeling safe
your kids
and they're not going to live
ping-ponging off the walls as much
they're still kids they're still going
to do that
but they're going to begin to feel safe
in the house
and they're going to begin to feel safe
in relationship with you guys
and what you're talking about now my man
is you're talking about generational
legacy change
you're talking about raising kids that
are never going to know the
disconnection and lack of validation
that your wife experienced
that you experience when she's hurting
you just want to reach across that aisle
you don't know how to do it
but if you cannot look at her as an hvac
unit but look at her as your soul mate
my man ron you're talking about new
family trees being planted in forests
and dude you're not going to get to eat
the fruit of these trees
but your great-grandkids will and man
i'm i'm glad that you're my last call of
the day um
you are leaving me with a smile on my
face because i know you're going to be a
guy who makes these major transitions
you're going to teach yourself new
skills you're going to learn new skills
and you're going to golly man wrap your
hands around your wife's heart it's
going to be awesome
i do want you to call me back in about a
month i want you to know how let me know
how things are going shoot me an email
i'll read it here on the air
i'm excited for you and your wife and
where y'all are headed that's awesome